you
I want to tell you how America still
works and maybe give you some tips how
to start a variety of businesses with
little to no money but she had touched
upon one thing in high school I was in a
high school class of my friend Michelle
Gilliam and I sat in front of Michelle
and we were still 11th grade we would
pass notes back and forth so we were
really clever she sat behind me so I
would like write a little note put it
and I'd like that you know lean back and
she'd grab it well one day mr. wax
intercepted our note and read it to the
whole class ah this Johnny guy and this
Michelle I'll read the note some stupid
like see it Winchell's you know after
school you know Darlene Googler and Ron
are gonna be there's something really
really silly you know we were just
buddies it's that they will never amount
to anything
well Michelle Gillian two days later I
should say two years later became
Michelle Phillips of the Mamas and Papas
who's an actress was a superstar and so
forth so my 50th birthday Michelle and I
have always remained friends she went
and found mr. wax and brought him to a
place called El Cholo in LA place we go
to for dinner after in high school
brought him there and we reminded him of
the situation and well I don't know I
want to tell you that America works
America works really really well and the
rest of the world is following
regardless of publicity that some people
put out yeah there are some things wrong
with our country but boy we're
straightening them out really quick we
the people are taking over in life
you're going to see things that you
think are real or read things that you
think are real sometimes they are and
sometimes they're not what is very real
is that the economy you're in today is
not what the press makes it out to be
I'll give you an example in 1980 when I
started John Paul Mitchell Systems with
my partner inflation was 12 and a half
percent what is it at one percent
interest rates were eighteen percent
wasn't how four or five six seven
percent unemployment was ten and a half
percent
and you had to wait in line for
sometimes blocks at a time to get
gasoline
you know actually most you weren't even
born then but that's how it was it
really really was it was a lot worse
than this today but yet people say yeah
look how bad the economy is maybe not
the best time to start a business in
1980 we started John Paul Mitchell
Systems with $700 that's it no loans
today is probably the largest
independently owned hair care
professional company in America and
growing were in 87 countries throughout
the world and growing quite rapidly but
America does work and our way of doing
things works no matter whether you agree
with the politicians you don't agree
with the politicians look around the
world a little bit why the uprising in
Tunisia why do you have uprisings in
Egypt where they didn't before and all
of a sudden in Iran they're saying wait
a minute you know we threw the show out
mullahs you're not doing any better you
know we want you why is this going on
well obviously as most of you know we're
the technological age where they have
email they have twitter they have
everything could ever imagine so they
know what's going on in the world more
people in the world want deservingly a
better chance a better opportunity to
least have the opportunity for a better
life and they're watching it now what's
going on throughout the world saying
well that's not so bad
maybe these bad guys aren't really that
bad maybe what's going on in America
where we the people hey Obama came in
man that guy gave great speeches I
thought oh I don't believe this guy he's
going to knock out immediately
pork-barrel spending it's going to be
gone he said he would intellection let's
go for this guy yay finally someone's
going to do something all of a sudden
every bill that went through had
pork-barrel spending so what did we the
people do we didn't wait four years two
years later we started kicking out
Democrats and putting in a more of
Republicans or independents because we
the people are speaking up we the people
don't want anymore all of a sudden the
Republican Party jumps in and says oh
we're going to stop pork barrel spending
even though it's been going on for years
we didn't do it during our
administration but we're going to do it
because Obama said he would and didn't
it's politics but the end result of
politics is things are changed they are
getting better I want to share with you
how to start a business with little to
no money using Paul Mitchell as a great
example of this and then also go into a
few the other things we do and maybe
some real secrets to success
want to start with two things is the
most asked questions of me John Paul
what is the main main thing we should
know to be successful in anything we do
and is there a second one and I'll tell
you those right off the bat the first
one is this and I'll explain it be
prepared for rejection be prepared for a
lot of rejection I don't care how good
your ideas no matter how unique it is
you're going to be knocking on doors or
talking to people to sell your services
or sell your product and your to get a
lot of rejection if you're aware of it
in advance it won't be like well this is
not a good idea
20 people said no you have to be able to
knock on door number 100 and be just as
enthusiastic on that door as you were in
the first hundred doors that were
slammed in your face be prepared in
advance for rejection I sold
encyclopedias door-to-door when I was 19
20 21 and 22 years old for Colliers
encyclopedia
I believed everyone needed a Colliers
encyclopedia a high school student could
understand it a college student could
tolerate it okay may not be Britannica
but everyone needed one so I sold them
door-to-door no appointments just went
out there knocking on doors and all of a
sudden if they let me in all these
bindings red and blue would come out but
I believe what I did was right
I had a lot of rejection door slammed in
my face all the time and people that
weren't very courteous but then again I
was calling on their homes in the late
afternoon throughout the evening I
wasn't expected there anyways
the average in Sackler pedia salesman in
those days lasted three days I lasted
four years and then I got out Commission
only but one of the things I learned was
believe if you believe what you're doing
is right don't give up the successful
people
do all the things the unsuccessful
people don't want to do that's number
two successful people do all the things
unsuccessful people don't want to do
like a door number 101 smiling and being
enthusiastic not giving up on what
you're doing and being really into it I
want to give you that's phase one part
one in part 2 the other secret to
success it's own category is whatever
service whatever products you are
selling make sure it's of the highest
quality in its category you could
possibly have you do not want to and I
would underline do not you do not want
to be in the selling business as most
everybody does I want to sell my service
I want to sell my product you don't want
that the big secret is you want to set
up your business so you're in the
reorder business your service or your
product is so darn good that people are
going to want it again or tell other
people you got to get this it's that
cool that's how you build a business you
start in the beginning saying it's going
to be so good that I'm going to be in
the reorder business people going to
want to talk about me people don't want
to say this is great how do you start a
major cosmetic company thirty years ago
during the worst economy in the United
States since the Great Depression the
real worst economy since the Great
Depression with $700 well we thought it
was impossible
I had my partner who was a hairdresser
his name was Cyril Thomas Mitchell he
used the name Paul Mitchell as a
hairdressing name and John Paul DeJoria
John Paul Mitchell Systems that's why we
got that name together and I was from
the business and the marketing in Italy
knew a little bit about product
formulation and my partner was a great
hairdresser like when the most
avant-garde ones Yuka Majan he knew
products he could use them so I said
Paul I've been in the industry myself as
an executive and I said why don't you
and I started coming together I'll raise
the five hundred thousand dollars we
need and you'll own 30 percent LM thirty
percent and the money will own 40
percent we had an invest
from the tax-free haven of Jersey
between England and France and dick hold
house with Citicorp set it all up for me
he was a friend of mine and then was all
set to go and that day I wasn't getting
off my wife wanted to get out of there
anyways I left or whatever money I have
left for the house a nice car with my
daughter plenty of money for a few
months you know and put a few hundred
bucks in my pocket jumped in my car and
went down to the bank my partner Paul
came over he was out of money too so he
came on over so we'll get our $500,000
in Paul eaters a few thousand for you
I'm gonna run an efficient co teller
apartment for a week or two or months I
see where I want to situate myself and
we're in business the money never came
in that night the money still never came
in what are we going to do dick old
house got ahold of me through a friend
of mine and said I got how to JP's 3:00
in the morning in England when he
finally gets a hold of me and see even
the banks are closed
so that ought to tell you this JEP but I
just have to the backer pulled out he
says inflation is such-and-such in the
United States 12 and 1/2 percent
interest rates 18 percent unemployment
is 10 and a half percent there's a fuel
shortage going on and your hostages
there's over four of them still in Iran
that they're holding they're not
released yet
I can't invest United States where there
oh my god no money great idea already
set up the bottle man I set up a silk
screener I set up everything to just
pull the trigger and go we didn't have
any money how do you start a business
with zero money so I'm going to give you
everything we did we did have an office
but I had a friend with the telephone my
office was an answering machine that you
could buy today for $29.95 I got a
friend of mine who had an English accent
and she said no John Paul Mitchell
Systems oh we're so busy but leave a
message we'll get with you it looked
like we were bigger there was just Paul
and I that was her office we need a
location I went to Universal City
California to little post office there
for $15
I got a peel box John Paul Mitchell
Systems peel Box 105 97 you
city california we had a phone we had a
second cherry didn't exist or someone
answering the phone that was it
for stationary I would go to a print
shop for three dollars they would
typeset and make me one copy that was my
stationery I would go to a photocopy
image place for four cents a copy and
make many copies and now it's stationary
and I'd let her head and I could draw on
there an invoice I can invoice people
okay fine you have a make-believe office
set up but how about the products well
everyone was set up to do a hundred
thousand of each bottle and you know
they were excited they were enthusiastic
we were enthusiastic I was excited
enthusiastic but nobody knew we didn't
have any money we didn't want to lie but
we didn't want to quite tell him
everything so I called up the silk skirt
the bottle man got started the bottle
guide said instead of ordering a hundred
thousand bottles I'd like to have a
sample run of ten thousand oh of course
we understand no problem we'll give to
you the same price called the silkscreen
or ten thousand are coming over and it's
a sample run I want three hundred
shampoo one three hundred shampoo two
and I mean three thousand and then I
want the other 4000 conditioner no
problem and by the way don't put the
color on because color was seven cents a
pass black and white was two cents so
our bottles came out black and white
turned out it was great unisex we didn't
know that we used to you with a lot less
than sunscreen them called the filler up
you got all the supplies we just need a
ten thousand fill three thousand of this
three thousand of that okay and all of a
sudden bingo the clock started ticking
from the time the silk screener got it I
mean the bottle guy got to the silk
screener got it to the filling house we
had him full was two weeks it was two
weeks longer because I'd set up credit
with everybody prior to this time 30 day
credit two weeks from now that first
bill is do I hit the streets knocking
door-to-door like I was selling
encyclopedias but I would go from beauty
salon to beauty salon to beauty salon we
had a shampoo that instead of using two
shampoos more product rinsing it down
the sink you know goes away you only
need one shampoo saves you time and
our conditioner you didn't put it in the
hair in the salon leave it for 10
minutes rinse it off you take the
customer to the station you sit them
down you put the condition in your hands
you show them you run it through their
hair and leave it and you tell your
customer this is a moisture treatment
this is a protein treatment it's going
to let me cut your hair easier and when
I blow-dry it it's going to cause less
damage to your hair because as a
protector so we knew that and by the way
hairdresser when you put in your hand
and you do this every time it
neutralizes all the chemicals in your
hand so I would go in and give a
presentation here's my product most
people would say well why do I need your
product you know I've got Soto's I've
got L'Oreal I've got rec and they go
down all you know regular companies
lines that I need your product you're an
unknown I said well here's what I'll do
if you will agree to take one dozen each
of what I have and use my shampoo and
conditioner at every station you have
I'll make this agreement with you and
display it by the way I level black and
white looks so good at eye level if you
will do that and you are not satisfied
as when the hottest products you've ever
used and recommend to your customers to
take home I will come back take every
bottle off the shelf you have not used
or sold out the door still a good bottle
you haven't used or sold yet I will give
your money back on all of it now is that
fair enough the answer was usually no we
don't need your product okay we have all
these other products there right finally
I'd say okay I can understand your
skepticism but if it works the way I say
it does and your customers love it and
you love it you're going to want to
recommend it I'll pay what I'll do if
you will agree to have it at eye level a
nice little display let me come in and
hold a little class for your stylist on
how to use it I will place only six
bottles of the shampoo six files the
conditioner six files of you know
everything in your salon and I'll also
give you this within one month 30 days
if you're I'm totally happy anything you
haven't used or sold out the door I'll
give your money back is that fair enough
and the same with your customers and
some would say yes someone say no I'd
say okay I can understand if I only gave
you two bottles and/or as amazing how if
you only took two bottle
six bottles I went around and I got 12
people to buy it head into my trunk so I
took it out here's your order
can I have the check they gave me the
check I went down to Paris ace beauty
supply in downtown LA who was calling on
salons and I said would you like to be
the disturber for this new hot line we
call it Paul Mitchell because my
partner's a hairdresser I'm not it'll
only be in the hairdressing industry
forever it's not going to be like Nexus
or Jared Mac or all these other
companies that sell you out
they let the hairdresser's build them up
and they go retail at their lines it'll
always stay in salons so that's what you
should buy our product here's how unique
it is he said we don't need to buy your
product we have a link Curtis we have
you just went on and on I said well hey
what if you knew customers were gonna
buy this would you take it on yeah but
who knows that you don't know for sure I
whipped out 12 orders put 12 checks
right in front of them and said that's
your first 12 orders and there's the
checks for them I haven't cashed him yet
for two thousand dollars in product you
could be my la distributor exclusively
for all of LA County and I'll come here
and help you sell it he looked at it
laughed his head off stay was Jim
Henriette laughed and said okay I said
what just one more thing when I deliver
the $2,000 I'm a new company I really
need a check he laughed and said hey we
pay our bills in 45 days well knowing
that in advance i priced my products at
5% over what I really wanted I said I'll
tell you what I'll give you a 5%
discount give me a check on the spot I
need the money I already had this in my
mind how do you get money right away
well whatever your price of your product
is up at 5% and give it right back to
them for paying you right away to this
state Paul Mitchell gets paid co D or
within 10 days and we still have to
fight for said in there
no one ever doesn't take it how you get
in the door so he said okay and I drove
around back to the warehouse
warehouse man this stuff is for you
could have a check he calls Jim
Henrietta we had Jean Henrietta about
ten years ago to one of our meetings to
tell everybody the story he says I'm
sitting in my office the phone rings in
my warehouse manager and he says you not
gonna believe some guy back here
unloaded products he wants to check he
says was he look like his name is John
Paul he was just in my office five
minutes ago
laughs gave us a check and that's kind
of how we took off with grassroots if we
wanted to cross the nation in those days
you could fly it for 99 dollars The
Midnight Special
from Los Angeles to New York hardly
anyone's on that plane you pick up the
little dividers you sleep on it and the
bathroom is your shower so you learn as
you go along various ways too shall we
say save money and two along the way
build a business now I want to talk to
you a little bit about also as you build
a business how to manage it we don't
lose people in 31 years John Paul
Mitchell Systems in 87 countries
throughout the world has had a turnover
of less than 30 people that's unheard of
people say how do I get a job at Paul
Mitchell there are no positions because
nobody wants to leave will occasionally
have a new one with expansion but we
treat people the way we want people to
treat us so I'd like to take a moment
because there's just so much to cover in
such a short period of time I want to
take just a moment with you to give you
some very important management
techniques that will last you for the
rest of your life and maybe some
personal techniques on getting along
with people I want to cover with you
right now how to reprimand somebody if
you're a manager or an owner of a
business whenever you reprimand somebody
if I went up to this lovely lady here
and told her what she did wrong she'd
feel really bad when we left each other
she wouldn't feel good at all there's a
way to reprimand somebody where they
feel really good when they leave before
you do it you need three things you want
to write down in a piece of paper what
it is they did wrong second of all you
want to write down so you know it how to
do it right you'd be amazed at how many
people get scolded for something they
didn't know how to do it right but they
won't admit it how to do it right
third thing is it's the last thing the
most important what do they normally do
really really good what do they know
when we do really really good that you
could tell them so they feel like
they're really wanted and they really
are someone that you appreciate and
respect and when they walk out they're
happy being reprimanded you know these
things when they call in and they come
on in
you always reprimand privately behind
closed doors never reprimand anybody in
front of anybody else you do and that's
covert hostility they'll stab in the
back whenever they can only reprimand
people behind closed doors and in
private first thing you do is you tell
them what it is they did wrong the
second thing how to do it right I'll
give an example okay you come in every
day on time and you're great people love
you but when you answer the phone you're
not smiling like hello can I help you
Stanford University or John Paul
Mitchell Systems if you smile like we
suggested before your brightness your
beauty comes across and the person the
other end of the phone knows it's a
happy company hi John Paul Mitchell
sister Stanford how can I help you big
difference you are incredible you come
in all the time people love you you bent
over backwards to help people out
because you're that cool and you do
everything that wonderful what would
expect you to do this thing also because
you're that you're that great at what
you do she walks out feeling good it's
the opposite it's the total opposite for
praising somebody whenever somebody did
something good praise them loudly and in
front of as many people as you can like
if there were people walking around that
worked with you oh my god you're
unbelievable you smile you made people
happy on the other the phone guys she is
too cool and it was tell them what they
did right in front of a lot of people or
make sure there's someone around so she
knows that someone else heard what she
did right or he did right
very important business the old school
was I want you to do this
why because I said so that is not
management the worst book ever written
in the world it was the bestseller 40
years ago it was called management
through intimidation terrible terrible
it was a book big sided how could any
but he possibly want to do that and the
other thing gets into treating people
how you'd want to be treated and not
lying about what you're going to do
we're the only major company left in the
professional beauty industry I could be
to three times my size if I opened up
the paul mitchell line two drugstore
supermarkets everybody but i don't i go
on TV and say if you ever see paul
mitchell in any drugstore supermarket
it's counterfeit or it's from the
black/gray market we don't put it there
don't buy it even the counterfeit
bottles say of guaranteed only what sold
in professional salon they're really
good don't buy it because we only sell
our product in salons that's all black
market grey market or counterfeit don't
buy it
because we're only in the beauty
industry we told hair stylists if we
make it we're going to be in the
professional beauty industry forever we
are never going to cut you out of the
picture
we'll never desert you when you build us
and they did so ethics is another good
thing if you're say you're going to do
something by gosh you want to do it you
want to do it right away another area
you want to touch on with you here
because very helpful and I know when I
was at various government agencies I do
some lecturing for some of our agencies
of CIA the FBI and I do lecture here and
there for the Secret Service and other
groups what I lecture on is management
motivation business and just a lifestyle
of being happy so everyone just feels
good and I feel that if you're a citizen
of any country and you want to change it
by gosh get in there motivate people if
I don't like the way someone's doing
something why do I get in there and talk
to their agents or talk to their people
about another belief a new way to do
things be a more loving kinder manager
where people want to do more for you on
a regular basis and don't want to leave
there have been times I've been to John
Paul Mitchell Systems corporate
headquarters at five in the afternoon
5:30 and half the offices full I said
get out of here go home what are you
doing get out of here no no we want to
finish this get out of here no no JP
it's ok we want to finish this because
they feel they are part of it and we
treat people as they should be treated
and there is free lunch by the way John
Paul Mitchell Systems everyone gets free
lunch we have utensils you know that so
they're recyclable
we bring food in big different
restaurants in large quantities
recyclable if you carpool we pay for
your gas we do unto others as we have
others do unto us and I'm not going to
get religious on you because I'm not
qualified but my feeling is that if God
wants you to do something and if you're
atheist let's say nature okay so I won't
get realistic nature the universe let's
just say God for just a good name to use
what God wants for people is to be happy
and love one another and treat one
another the way you want to be treated
not bashing people squashing him down or
killing them a name of God he doesn't
want that he wants all people to be
happy respect one another not step on
anybody we have a hundred and ten Paul
Mitchell schools throughout the United
States Oh fifteen thousand students in
them and there's something we have
that's different than the other school
is called a culture you have to learn
the culture while you're there yes you
will learn if you go to a Paul Mitchell
school how to be a great hair stylist
how to be a great haircut or a great
hair colorist you will learn all this
how to merchandise market display but
you'll learn a culture that I think
every University every high school just
every school should teach and they don't
and the culture is how you love yourself
people around you how to communicate
with people you haven't communicated
with in years how to break that bound
and how to take care of your own
community your own state your own
country and the whole world everyone
that goes to our school participates for
a couple of months into a fundraising
program and if you do really really well
2,500 of you get all expenses paid to
Las Vegas for a special training program
in a concert and just the best time in
the world but when you raise the money
all the charities we pay for not one
dime of the money they raise goes to
anything but the actual charity itself
everything from Alzheimer's disease to
helping people Children's Miracle
Network to feeding orphans in Africa
where their parents have died of AIDS a
roundabout thing well these students and
by the way last year they raised 1
million two hundred thousand dollars
students okay well they ever meet the
orphans in Africa no well they ever meet
the people have Alzheimer's disease
where you're teaching their family or
the organization is teaching them how to
deal with people are losing their memory
no probably never well well they meet
some of these kids that we help out
where they're not turned down from for
any medical reason to hospital
no probably never well but why do they
do it because they know while they are
alive and a student and in their life
they can give back and change their
country and the world for a better place
to live because they are here somehow
participating well in the participation
it starts with you we talked to people
about how to love yourself you may come
in one day everything went wrong you're
really bummed out which happens to
everybody we're humans well here's an
affirmation you could read or here's how
to talk to another student or one of the
instructors about it or ears how to do
with yourself the biggest one is this
and you don't have to raise your hands
because what I'm going to tell you is
going to affect more than 50% of the
people in this room but I'll tell you
about it I'll take out overcome it and
go forth and be happy
many times in life from your younger
days your school days maybe right now
there may have been someone in your life
it could be your mother brother father
relative dear friend significant other
husband wife something in your life
there was a communication break some of
your life was pretty pretty close to you
you wanted to be closer to them
something happened
all of a sudden you're not close to one
another anymore something happened
example is do divorces when you first
met your husband your wife your
significant other whatever when you
first met somebody in your life
boyfriends girlfriends they were the
most important person oh you couldn't
separate us but so many months or years
later in them not liking each other
sometimes it's in school sometimes this
is relative it just happens in life
because for humans now if I were a
knight Kate you're the closest I've
became used to you if we if you confront
the person they're going to be human boy
you know you were really wrong in high
school you passed all those terrible
rumors about me and that you never
apologized you were wrong
first thing she's going to do is say
absolutely not that's not how it went
look what you did people are normally
defensive it's the first thing that
happens you're going to defend your
position it's normal it's human but
we're at it again how do I break that
bond with my mom my dad brother sister
uncle with anybody I allow her to be
free enough to tell me anything she
wants and the way I do it is this we
were the best friends call him on the
phone or see him face to face either way
hi we were I have to talk to you this
about my mind so long we were the best
of friends we grew up together grammar
school junior high high school and all
of a sudden something happened whatever
I did whatever I said or did to offend
you please forgive me that's not me I'm
a different person That's not me
will you please forgive me for whatever
I may have said or done that offended
you please it's not me
well in half the cases the other person
says oh my god I'm so glad you called me
oh my god I mean want to call you for
years it wasn't you as me there's less
talk and you're crying you're happy you
have coffee or tea or shot of patron
together or something huh or shampoo
your hair with Paul Mitchell yeah in
other words something all of a sudden
you allowed the bond to be broken if you
do this with people 90 percent of all
people are going to respond and say oh
my gosh I'm so glad you call me yeah
this went wrong let's talk about it what
happened and in many cases it was
somebody said something to you about
someone else that wasn't true there's
this great book written called The Four
Agreements
four ways to live your life and I
believe was the second agreement and the
author was Don Miguel Ruiz rui-zi the
second agreement is never gossip or
listen to gossip because if you listen
to gossip and tell somebody else all of
a sudden they'll tell somebody else it
spreads now you find out what you were
told was not true now do you go back to
everyone said no that that wasn't true
tell everybody you told that was a lie
somebody told me a rumor you can't it's
out of control
don't pass gossip or ever listen to
gossip in
may not be true and you're not going to
live a happy life if you do that and you
know people in your lives that you know
just want to tell the scoop all the bad
stuff that's going on well that's your
choice you hang out with people and want
to all the bad stuff or hang out people
wanting the good stuff out how to make
things better in life opposed to all
that's going on wrong so look at how
cool our lives are look at all that's
going on wrong there also what does
giving give you if you give to somebody
that never says thank you never knows
you did it what is your reward for it
I'd like to give you a little example of
philanthropy when I was six years old I
grew up my mother my brother and I we
grew up in Echo Park LA downtown LA we
had very very little we had food on the
table two changes of clothes extra
t-shirt pair of shoes every week same
pair though a gentle head holds enough
and it's we didn't have a lot but we
never knew it when I was six years old
my mom took my brother and I to downtown
Los Angeles
they had trolley cars in those days five
cents this is early 1950s tried the
trolley car for a nickel and then at
Christmastime there'd be all these fine
department stores Bullock's may come
these beautiful department stores and
these giant windows the hell he's cooled
Christmas decorations puppets that move
trains going around and my mom one day
took ten cents and gave it to my brother
and I said boys each one of you hold
this and together walk up with this time
and put in the bucket of that guy ring
in the Bell we did went back and said
mom why do we give that guy bringing the
bell on the bucket ten cents that's
three candy bars to Coca Cola's remember
this early 50s okay that was a lot of
money right and my mom said to us boys
is to let you know something life no
matter how bad off you think you are
there's always someone worse off in you
that's a Salvation Army and those people
really hurt most don't have places to
live and people have to feed them so
it's a good thing son so that kind of
stuck in the mind but I'll give you the
example of the most ultimate high
now older than you guys most of your
probably born in the 60s and 70s well I
was there in the 60s a little different
aramis I'm gonna give you an example of
the ultimate hi Paul Mitchell I didn't
say any I'm just have a give an example
of the Altamaha okay that's all
didn't say I did anything it did say I
didn't did say anything okay the
ultimate high it took a lot of people
asked us to when did you know Paul
Mitchell hair care products John Paul
Mitchell Systems was going to be
successful two years after I started the
company because two years after I
started was the first time we could pay
our bills on time didn't pay him off but
paid him on time it took that long every
week was please the checks in the mail
don't cut me off
well DeLand delivered the day after
tomorrow noise sent of the wrong address
in other words it was miserable I can
remember not sleeping at nights I
couldn't pay my bills did it help no but
I didn't sleep anyways we just aw God so
it was a big deal every week for almost
two years we should have gone out of
business if you felt followed a textbook
how to do things you would say guys go
bankrupt go bankrupt go bankrupt there's
no hope for you he can't even pay your
bills and the black and white of course
was two cents opposed to the seven cents
for the color when we hired our first
person one person a year and a half
later that's what I had our first
employee in the field had to do ten jobs
so he built a company with fewer moving
parts so two years later our bills are
finally paid on time we have $2,000 in
the bank age we immediately took a
dividend and felt on top of the world oh
my god it's 1982 now our bills are paid
on time we have $2,000 each so I'm going
to do something I've never done in my
life when I went to a restaurant I went
to El Torito Marina del Rey it's a chain
of restaurants all over the place and I
went down there and if you look at a
menu well here when you open a menu up
right okay here it shows you what you
get and over here on the right side is
the price well if I ever went to a
restaurant I would go the price first
see what you got came over here and see
what you get for it where's how much was
it 395 okay so this time okay I'm going
to El Torito I'm and took a friend with
me and I'm an order anything I want off
the left side of the menu carne asada
you know big margarita didn't have
patron yep it was okay they
Margareta big hoard of guacamole whoa
cool some with my friend their corner of
the room their top of the world in front
of me is a table of 12 children one
Hispanic lady at one end one
afro-american lady at the other end with
her back to me and all these children
Caucasian Asian black wipe everything
every color there was like a rainbow
sitting there and they were from the
inner city I knew because I'm from the
inner city and you know they dress yeah
I knew you just tell well the mom held
it up like this that menu did what I was
doing before
395 what do you get it was obvious that
they had a very limited budget she was
ordering for a little children there and
it was someone's special day I don't
know what made me do this it just did I
got up I walked into the kitchen after I
did calculations okay 12 13 14 they pick
out what's the most is going to cost
them I came to two hundred some odd
dollars okay now I got two thousand the
bank a credit card I walked into the
kitchen after the waiter and I said
those kids sitting in from you those two
moms tell him to order anything they
want
tell him the bills going to be picked up
and the tips going to be picked up
anything they want but don't tell him
who's doing it now I don't know why I
said that I don't know why fall in the
kitchen it was just the thing to do
sometimes in life the thing to do comes
at you if it does do it just do it don't
question just do it as long as it
doesn't hurt anybody came up I went and
sat down and he told the lady and this
lady must have been an evangelist big
woman with an angelic voice she stood up
she's about that far from he stood up
turned around looked at me can't be this
guy slowly looked around slowly looked
around the entire restaurant maybe it
took her half a minute he was that slow
that's a long time look around a
restaurant and ended up with me not this
guy obviously and I was you know not
even looking at her anyway she stands up
with her back to me maybe two feet from
me her arms raised in the most angelic
voice she must have let a choir or
something and she said loudly this
restaurant whoever you are
god bless you you have no idea what
you're doing for me and these children
the place went silent looked at her God
thank you and sat down as she did that
goosebumps friend if I whenever I tell
the story there's still goosebumps they
run up and down my arms he's ran over my
body I was high as a kite oh my god did
I feel like I was wow this was who what
heaven is like I did something for
somebody else never s18 return she still
didn't never knew when I walked out I
felt so unbelievable that day in the
next day and what made me feel good was
I do what humans should do something for
somebody else asking nothing in return
you're war reward far exceeds any thank
you
you know you did it you know you wanted
nothing in return but doing something
while you're on the planet Earth to make
it a better place live because you are
here now I know we're limited for time
and I want to have some time for
questions here so let me open this up
now and as you know I'm in a variety of
businesses patron did start by the way
21 years ago we started patron I'll tell
you that just real fast we wanted to
give a the world the finest mellow is
tequila on the planet so my partner mr.
Crowley and I put this together went
down there and patron is made out of the
finest Highlander Blue Agave that ever
existed when we started the company it
was so expensive to make it
we knew America wanted to treat itself
with something that was good in mellow
not holding your breath when you drink
tequila we wanted something that was
higher-end
that once you drank it you'd want to
reorder it big problem the most
expensive tequila's then were five six
seven ten dollars maybe $14 a bottle it
was so expensive to make patron we had
to sell it for 35 to 37 95 a bottle in
1989 who's going to pay that it was the
best people started drinking and Wow are
not told my breath anymore I could drink
this straight Wow
I'm not hungover the next day now if you
drink a whole bottle you're going to get
hungover but you know but nori it's not
the same as regular tequila I want to
treat myself and it slowly grew we were
the first to ever introduce would you
call a high-end ultra premium tequila
through
the United States of America today
patron is the number one ultra premium
tequila in the world we're in 120
countries 109 rap songs and hip hop
songs have been written about patron
three country-western songs and two pop
songs okay we don't pay for any of this
in lots of movies that people appreciate
it one it was the best quality it was
the fight and still is today it is the
finest tequila you could ever buy today
and the best we think for your body and
we even use our distill egde and making
it a fertilizer instead of pollute in
the land that's how we feel about it and
of course it's also the second largest
selling tequila in the world even though
it's the highest and ultra premium if
you take all the inexpensive ones
combine them all together we're number
two in the world by bottle number one by
far as the top ultra premium
highest-quality there was finest
packaging but more important we also
give back not only do we make patron in
the old fashioned way little stills but
we have an orphanage down there I have
an old folks home down there we
rebuilding houses for the st. Bernard
project in Louisiana our staff goes down
there to help rebuild houses we believe
in giving back and giving a lot of love
do you have any questions or comments
because I could beer for hours with you
gone through all the companies what we
did how we started it but let's take a
few minutes with you any comments
criticisms any questions you have on
anything I might be able to answer for
you
anybody hands there you go there start
with you sir everybody just we even have
a mic so I hear a lot of people that
have your entrepreneur story where they
sold encyclopedias or they I mean what
do we do today that's the equivalent of
selling cycle videos door-to-door what's
something street smart that we can all
do anything you want to sell any idea
any product whatever it is just go out
and do it that's the equivalent of
selling something new door-to-door I had
an encyclopedia you know though and they
don't have door-to-door sales
encyclopedias anymore if they did every
one of my kids would be forced to do
that for at least six months no matter
how they did if I had to subsidize them
just for the experience I would say it's
anything anything if you want the
experience of going
door to door why don't you go and make
up a little booklet or make up an
information packet on what your starting
right now take two or three or four
pages do a whole report on what you're
doing and go door to door and say hi I'm
a student you know here at Stanford
University this is five pages I want
people to know about the subject it's
only $1 you know here's what it is the
dollar goes to me helps with the
education but I think it's interesting
and here's why that's one example
selling yourself and your idea just one
example you want to just test it out but
I think if you say you're a student from
Stanford they'll probably be a little
more accommodating
you know opposed to hey I have this
bushel of potatoes and I bought it for
five dollars but I'm gonna let you have
it for four it's the best potato in the
world you know in other words your own
idea your own thoughts is a great way to
get started on anything or grab some
charity any charities you firmly believe
in and just go knocking on doors how I
want to tell you a little bit about food
for Africa I want a little bit about
kids play new part here in Palo Alto
anything just need the experience
yes sir thanks for talking to us today
when you were losing money in your first
business what I guess what was the
threshold at which he said after this
point I'm going to declare bankruptcy
when everyone said you should be
declaring bankruptcy right away and what
can be going okay we start losing money
from day one but I knew that if I could
tell enough hairdressers about this
product and get them to use it it was
better than anything ever used in their
life and they'd want to continue to use
it it's just how many people can I talk
to and keep on chasing the bill
collector you know and at the same time
you know get the job done I believed
enough in it for months later we
invented something called sculpting
lotion and it became a trend two years
later so you put this lotion on it
didn't flake you had the wet look or you
brushed it out you had the dry fluffy
look or if you had straight hair you put
it on put waves in your hair let it dry
they would stay there brush your hair
the ways are still there rinse it out it
disappears instantly no buildup but
nobody knew it it was all word of mouth
word of mouth so we knew that we wanted
to be in the reorder business so I knew
I would tell enough people we'd be able
to keep up with our supply so we had no
money
every dime we had that came in was
inventory and since we had no inventory
was hand to mouth hand to mouth hand to
mouth but we believe we are in and we
knew it because the first few people
would reorder we just didn't have a lot
of customers way to get out there and do
it
hope that answers your question okay for
you questions comments criticisms yes
sir yes why do you take a chance on you
well I was in the beauty industry
working for major companies for nine
years and I started out as a salesperson
with one company and became their
national manager in a year and a half so
then I got into marketing so was obvious
in sales and marketing in the
professional beauty industry and you
exactly what I was doing there was no
doubt is mine very good
how does size of your partner very
important whether it's your family your
friends or someone you never met the
first thing is feel the energy how many
people you around you just feel
uncomfortable around them you get
something like that that's not your
partner yeah when you feel that the
universe the the the frequency of this
planet is rising right now and more and
more people could feel other people out
a lot quicker than ever before first
thing is if you feel a lot around
somebody that's not your partner
next thing is write on a piece of paper
here's what you bring to the partnership
what can the other person bring to the
partnership other than just money if it
is money and where's what influence what
can they do to help build your business
and how are they planning to do it
interview them like you're interviewing
for a position a partner what can you
bring to it and why do you like this why
do you think we're going to make it
together and what are you willing to do
and do we like each other also go to
breakfast or lunch with them go to
breakfast or lunch them hang out a
little bit just don't rely on interviews
sometimes you have breakfast and you
have lunch or a dinner you get to know
the person you get to see them in a
social environment not just a business
environment so get it home first and get
that feeling for that person what
they're going to bring to the table is
it synergistic Senate resume meaning one
plus one doesn't equal two equals three
four five
20 is that going to happen when the two
of you together is going to be a
synergistic thing where you each bring
something to one another and you know
you like each other if you don't like
each other that's not your partner if
they're a mean person that's not your
partner if when you're talking to them
they criticize other people that's not
your partner
they don't believe on a nice positive
way of life that's not your partner if
they're not honest that's not your
partner they don't want to make the
world a better place to live that's not
your partner if they're not exciting
that's not your partner and you don't
have to be an extrovert to be excited
you just have to believe what you're
doing is really cool and you have like a
quite excitement it's excited any other
questions yes we should next nominal
entrepreneurial successes that were
preceded by emotional and financial
hardship yes I'm assuming that you've
had several others odd that proved
unsuccessful and I'd like to know what
your internal dialog was like throughout
those you know ventures and what you
told yourself to kind of keep going okay
well in using that let me give you a
better example to answer your question
of things that weren't successful I was
in my car there was no money and what
little money we had $700 between Paul
and I that paid for the silk screener
period I had no money I went to my mom
did not tell her how things works I was
doing well a nice home on Mulholland
Drive said mom cover a few hundred bucks
right now I'm just short with cash
oh sure son everything okay yeah it's
fine and the big failure was how am I
going to eat and sleep for the next
couple of weeks well I'm selling this
and the stuffs coming in to sell how am
I going to exist that was the biggest
challenge of them all and I knew no
matter what I'll somehow figure a way to
get by this one no matter what I slept
in my car for two weeks I showered at
Griffith Park
did public showers down there for 99
cents I went to the freeway cafe you
find these things out when you're really
hurting you know how do you overcome
this problem when to the freeway cafe
for 99 cents after nine o'clock they
wanted people to come by truckers say
give you one egg one piece of toast or
sausage or buy
and one glass of juice or coffee and
you're toast so I had one egg sausage
was a bigger one one sausage one piece
of toast one orange juice that was my
breakfast Wellcome the afternoon you're
getting hungry well at a lot of these
big places these big chains to get
people to come in there and order at
4:30 to 6:00 o'clock they have happy
hour 99 cents any well drink you want so
I go in there for 99-cent margarita and
they also had food to keep you there
I'll tell you 20 chicken wings later and
a whole bunch of salsa
you had your vegetables your full meal
and you're feeling good and then so
that's how I survived and still put some
gas in the car then got this business
going to the first cell was able to be
made along the way other little business
is that I started one was a consulting
business a year before I started John
Paul Mitchell Systems I was a consultant
I knew the beauty industry inside and
out if I went to you and you could pay
me I told you everything you had to know
in 3 months you need me anymore
I was out of a job if you really needed
me badly I was running your company for
you and it was 2 to 3 weeks behind
trying to pay me that was going nowhere
so I moved on to something else also
since Paul Mitchell and of course Patron
tequila John pulp and other adventures
I've started other little things and
then quite work as well but I did have
Paul Mitchell there you know as my
backstop so it wasn't really a thing
that was overly challenging the biggest
one was Paul Mitchell and eating and
finding a place to sleep which was my
car and existing for a couple of weeks
and still put your jacket on and your
stuff in the car to deliver where nobody
knows you're really down and out that
was really the tough one but I believe
what we did was right there was a young
lady here first we'll get you sir yes
ma'am
yes correct the conditioner in your hair
is a leave-in conditioner yes a little
bit about how that played into the
timing of that and the innovation of the
juggling perms and you betcha
great question part of a movement you
got it and you were in the timing
well the timing was incredible because
here you had people and salons that had
a perms were a big deal in those days
had a perm people's hair for example and
yet people backed up so we looked at
what a salon need well maybe we cut some
time there one shampoo instead of two
and you pick up another 10 minutes if
you're not rinsing and putting the
condition on the back basin so that's
time and money that's unique also as you
said about perms during the time and
blow-drying people were perming and
blow-drying permeant blow and just
ruining their hair and when they had
perms this leave-in conditioner you
could leave in your hair as a perm when
it dried instead of freaking out on you
it was under control he had all the
curls in so the time he had a lot two of
the - it was a good time it was a good
time to come in we saw the need in the
marketplace find the need in the
marketplace that someone else didn't
find and push that or find the need in
the marketplace that no one else is
promoting and promote it yes sir got a
question over here okay
I wanted to ask your question okay I
wanted to commend your your attrition
rate with your employees but can you
speak a little bit of an employee
selection sure first thing I do when we
interview people and up until a year ago
I interviewed everybody but now we're
getting pretty big in a few countries so
I have to rely on my president to do
some interviewing with me but it's just
what I told this other young man about
finding a partner if I'm interviewing
you the first thing I'm going to do is
all have your resume in front of me but
I'm not going for your resume I'm going
for how I feel about you and the energy
that's coming from you to me I'm going
for the sole not for the thing the soul
is occupying and not the resume that you
filled out look at the resume and refer
to various things on the resume I go
straight towards the person one girl for
example that heads up
part of my research in my trade
marketing department I went to the
Primeau no mall and she was there at
Christmas time for charity trying to
raise money she was the happiest most
incredible lady I've young lady 20 years
old later ever met
oh how you doing oh we have this charity
here and you don't have to give us a lot
of money but on your way out of you want
to give us a quarter anything it helps
the kids I could not believe this
personality as I left I said if you're
ever interested boy do I have a job for
you at John Paul Mitchell Systems yeah I
don't have a job right now other than
helping charities
she was my receptionist her personality
was so overwhelming that year we gave
everybody bonuses in the year that year
she got one of the biggest bonuses in
the company and she was a receptionist
because of what you do I go for the
person I go right for the person the
sole how do I feel about that person
then I go into some of the necessities
that we might need for the job you know
some of the things that bill can you use
a computer you know can you talk on a
phone you know I mean can you ride you
know and we go towards you know other
things with the technical things but the
first thing is I go for that soul I go
for the entity again the frequency of
the planet is rising people are becoming
more aware and you say well how can you
prove this I'll prove it to you with one
statement per capita because a lot more
people in this planet than there ever
was before
per capita there are more individuals
and groups into philanthropic endeavors
or what can I do to help the planet and
others out more than ever in the history
of this planet per capita not just
because of a large population frequency
has something to do with it think of you
when you watch TV or listen to the news
or you read things in books years ago
they've changed it aren't so true if it
will wait a minute
that's not right I'm going to challenge
this why is this the way it is I don't
think that's right maybe you know we've
been believing this all along maybe
there's something else that could be
true like the world is flat no I think
it's round I'm gonna sail around it the
frequency is rising and more and more
people are going for it they say 2012
and I'll finish in 5 10 seconds 2012
Mayan calendars en role is going to
collapse look what's going on in the
Middle East explosions Armageddon I
think what's going to happen is in 2012
is the frequency is rising and people
are becoming so
aware that all peoples are saying this
is wrong this is right we want more of
what's right and we don't mind helping
one another out one of the biggest
things that ever happened on television
a week and a half ago was in Egypt after
they took over their own government
there was a day I've never seen like
this no one could ever imagine it there
was a day there were Christians and
Moslems were together they made a flag
of the Christian cross and the [ __ ]
symbol and they said were uniting
together as Christians and Moslems we
both want our freedom and we're going
forth together as one whatever you
believe in you believe in my way may be
different than yours but we're not going
to kill you or we're not going to
degrade you because of it we're going
forward and it was all over the streets
all over the news I thought wow they
should ran that for many many days not
just one day the frequency of our planet
is changing it's going in a great
direction so you've got some good things
look forward to thank you for taking
your time to be here with me and give me
a chance to chat with you